you're just surrounded sometimes even 15
20 people that come around
it's tough it's not easy but the guys
that were sat here went off out of that
exit and when we come over you see
there's a knife dug into the floor
you wouldn't think to maybe search in a
children's play area but this is just a
reality for us
north london one of the capitals most
violent boroughs
officers are heading to help search for
two teenagers on stolen hire bikes
if they've just tried to evade you um
they're trying to cross the road now
[Music]
are you renting this bike at the moment
uh yes have you got proof of proof of
your rent i ain't got no proof but i've
been riding this back for a long time
right michael just found cannabis
grinder on you is there going to be any
kind of stuff tell us now so we can stay
honest
with you okay within seconds of this
stop and search
locals are beginning to gather
with questions for the officers and
accusations the teenagers
have been racially profiled no no no
hold on
okay this gentleman's black but the
other individual
is white as well officers say this kind
of reaction has become the norm
is why we're all stood here now okay
black lives matter protests and
controversies
over stop and search have dramatically
raised tensions
within the black community everyone will
murder and everyone wants to know which
everyone has the right to i guess to an
extent find out what's going on and
see how we're policing but it is it's
tough
it's not easy these officers are from
the mets violence suppression unit
a new london-wide initiative using local
officers
with local knowledge to form teams
dedicated
to tackling the upsurge in violent crime
in this local park they are conducting
weapon searches
and it doesn't take them long to find
something the buyers that were sat here
went off out of that exit
off towards west green and when we come
over you see there's a knife dug into
the floor
and there's a pair of drugs as well we
have a lot of people here like families
and kids
everyone's trying to enjoy their day and
have a good time and you see you've got
a family there with a baby and a pram
and these guys
see them weapons ready for you know i
know they think they're sitting
themselves but
this could happen at any time with
whoever's about and they don't care
just yards away another knife stashed in
a litter bin
that could do a lot of damage just got
to hit the one wrong place and you're
gone
and it's not just knives the gangs use
as weapons
these two cricket bats have been found
stashed in the bush here
um normally in a park it wouldn't be
suspicious because the fact that it's
just two cricket bats on their own
hidden away sort of uh suggests that it
might be used as a potential offensive
weapon or something like that no ball no
cricket team no exactly
so just just weapons stashed away
deliberately hidden chris pretty grew up
in this area
he now helps divert young people away
from violence
he has some sympathy for the police but
believes
they still need to learn how to better
connect with the community
why don't we solve for it like before
it's been a problem and i feel like the
police officers need to understand
the way they conduct themselves i know
it's a tough job don't like they're done
if they do they're damned if they don't
if they don't stop and search and they
see someone and that person ends up
getting stabbed or that
someone ends up getting injured people
are going to be like where was the
police to stop and search
if the police stops and searches and
it's like you're harassing them you go
what are you doing all you do is stop
and search the little kids but during
the time it's the black kids and
everything so they've got to really
start understanding their community
the question of how best to take weapons
off the streets
but avoid the perception young black men
in particular
are being targeted is complex no one
really has the answer
but senior officers say saving lives
must be a priority
63 of the current homicide victims have
been from bme communities
i think that's a really important point
to remember so i'll put
my officers into those areas to try and
prevent
violence and serious crime
and and that's what the community wants
us to do so it's a really important
area of police work staircase on this
housing a stated group of youths have
ran off from officers
around the corner they found one of them
a 14 year old
and again a crowd is quickly forming
him they have no ground if he's got a
friend
he's racist you see these
officers found a small amount of
cannabis on the boy
that did little to ease the volatile
nature of those gathering all
of your races right here you're just
surrounded ten sometimes even 15
20 people that come around and you
haven't had individual chats with every
single person trying to tell them listen
it's not what you think it's not what
you're trying to make out to be just
listen to me we physically can't
have these exhausting conversations with
20 people all at once
so it's it's really tough it's
exhausting i think my colleagues would
agree
you don't engage with the community so
the community only feel like you come in
here when it's emergency you throw
around your authority
you brutalize our young people in a
sense so we've got to be fair majority
of people that get stopped
is black people eighty percent is more
likely to be stopped because you're
black but we don't count for eighty
percent of the population so that
doesn't make any sense
by evening the focus shifts to an
unlicensed music event
in finsbury park these gatherings are
often attended by gangs
and the police are increasingly seen as
a target
and although they move initially within
the hour the almost inevitable violence
[Applause]
officers i've spoken to are worried
community tensions they say
haven't been this high in many years
there is real concern
about the possibility of more serious
disorder
in the weeks ahead our quiet skins